Here is my solution. I think it is a little bit simpler.
The total number of lines of code is not that much different,
but I think it's easier to follow this way.
What I said is let's pick out the light from the state,
and let's take all the travelers a and b from within the state indexed by that light
with 0 being here and 1 being there.
Let's find the individual successor states that results from those two travelers,
or they might be one and the same--a and b traveling from that state.
I broke out this single successor function.
That just says we start where the light is, and we go to where the light isn't.
If the light was on side 0, then we go from the start to the destination,
and the light now is on side 1, and we're going in that direction.
Otherwise, we're going in the other direction.